Have you heard of the illuminati it's a name given to several secret Societies Throughout History
Both Real and Fictitious and The Debate About Whether the Organization still exists Rages on to this day?
Sheriff [The] Purpose of the illuminati Is often debated [are] They Looking [to]
Overthrow Humanity and Create A new World order Are They Constantly Protecting the World from Threats That the general public don't even Know exist or
Are [They] Just a group of Millionaires or?
Geniuses Who get Together for A few Beers Every Now and then nobody really Knows the fact That they're A secret society
Means That's Kind of Their Shtick but it's fun and Sometimes
Worrying to Theorize Such Theories Have Led to some
Conspiracists Believing That Illuminati Symbolism Is all Around us sometimes Even in The Movies that's what this Video is all about
Here Are 10 Dark secrets Hidden in Your Favorite Hollywood movies Now you just sit Quietly at Cooperate
The All-Seeing eye in The Pyramid
The All-Seeing
Eye in The Pyramid is the Symbol that Is most often associated with the Illuminati and it's been Seen in Countless Movies over the Years
for Starters it Is extremely Prominent on the Posters and Promotional
Material for 2004's National Treasure Like [These] a Movie in Which nicholas Cage's Benjamin Franklin gates [A] historian and Amateur Cryptology
Searches for A long Lost Treasure but you can
Also See it in the likes of Lara Croft Tomb Raider the Harry Potter Movies Doctor strange and on the Poster for 127 Hours
conspiracists Believe This Kind of Thing represents The illuminati's Influence in Hollywood
Social Change Conditioning Some conspiracists believe that the illuminati are Planning A
Population Calling Epidemic and That They're Attempting to Desensitize Us to it and Prepare Us for it by creating
Horrible Versions of Such Scenarios in Hollywood Movies Zombie Movies on the like such as
World war Z 28 Days Later [I] am legend land of A dead Maggie and Shaun of the dead are Prime
Examples of This Subtle Conditioning While the Likes of Outbreak Contagion Pandemic and Even Movies from as far back as
1950s Panic in The Streets Could be Considered to [have] been Made for the Same Purpose
Welcome to Earth Alien Invasions in A similar vein To the Previous entry About Conditioning Society for a planned
Population Calling Epidemic Is believed by some Conspiracy Theorists that the illuminati are Trying to Prepare the World for an Imminent Alien Invasion by Portraying
Such Events in Movies Blockbusters like war of the Worlds independence Day Battleship Battle los
Angeles Signs Mars attacks 10 Cloverfield Lane and the day The earth Stood Still are Prime examples [of] This
Downright We are your friends?
the Illuminati
Supposedly [Believe] That by
Conditioning Us in This way will Accept aliens upon Their arrival on our Planet as either a threat or as our evolved God's
Mind Control and Hypnotic triggers it is believed by some
Conspiracy Theorists That the illuminati used mind Control [and] Hypnotic Triggers to activate Their Subjects to Carry out Missions on Their Behalf
Project Marduk
Was a real-Life example of an Initiative
Supposedly Designed To Create Mind Controlled Slaves for the illuminati This has Been Represented in Countless Movies over the Years
Including The Likes of the Manchurian Candidate in Which the Queen of Diamonds Triggers a sleeper agent to become an Assassin
Telefon in Which Words from A Robert Frost Poem activate Human Time bombs
Zoolander in Which The Song Relax Is used to trigger A
Model to Assassinate the Malaysian Prime [Minister] and Captain America Civil war in Which trigger Words Turn Bucky Barnes Into the Deadly winter Soldier
With These Mother Snakes on This mother Fly Serpents Reptiles and Dragons?
Serpents Reptiles and Dragons all of Which are Largely Feared Creatures Have Long been Used to symbolize the
Cold-Blooded and Callous Ruling Elite Namely the illuminati this has Been Happening since the Days of ancient myths but it Occurs in modern Form in
Hollywood Blockbusters Creatures of This Nature on Film might Be More Than what they Seem in Some Conspiracy sighs at least
Examples of This include Movies Like Snakes on a Plane Python Anaconda rain
of Fire The Hobbit Series of Films Dragon Wars [Deewar] the Jurassic Park Franchise and The Godzilla Movies all of Those Movies present the Creatures
In Question as Fearsome and Powerful the type of Which Humans Should be Extremely wary, of?
Goddesses With Flaming Torches
Goddesses Particularly Those Bearing a Torch Or
Eternal Flame Have Long Been Used as a perverse Symbol of the enlightened Ones Aka the illuminati for Example
Babylonian Queen Semiramis and her Countless Aliases Can Be Seen Placed in Prominent Positions
Throughout The illuminati Controlled Institutions of the World Conspiracy Theorists believe it is the Illuminati
Influencing Such Imagery in Movies Imagery of this Nature Can be Seen in Any Movie Distributed by Columbia Pictures [Such] as the karate Kid
Ghostbusters The Spider-Man Movies and The Grudge Because Their Logo is a Torch [bearing] goddess it can, also be Seen
Whenever The Statue of Liberty Is Featured in A movie Such as an Escape from new York Ghostbusters 2
Cloverfield X-Men and the day after Tomorrow
Alternate Realities and Illusionary Worlds There's A Common Belief amongst
Conspiracy Theorists That the illuminati might be The Overseers of an Alternate Reality or illusionary World that, We all believed to be real This?
Is the Construct Because the secret society wants to conceal Humanity's True Purpose with that in mind the
Conspiracists Believe in Such Realities and Movies Are Teaching us about our actual Reality examples of Movies in Which Alternate Realities Are Prevalent
Include The Likes of The Matrix Franchise
[Inception] Dark City The mist event Horizon and
Doctor Strange it's Pretty Scary to think [that] the Theorist might be Right About this one in Particular
666 the Number
666 is Typically Most associated With Satan but Conspiracy Theorists Have Long believed that it has Been Adopted by the illuminati to
Unashamedly Display in Plain Sight Their Allegiance to the Dark Side the number is Regularly Seen in Hollywood and the
Conspiracists Believe it's There to Show the illuminati's Influence Most Notably it can Be Seen in The Disney Logo [but] it's
Also Appeared in A number of Films for example it can, be Seen to Simulate it Into the Clothing of Harry Potter Villain Bellatrix Lestrange
Whenever Anybody Gives the A, ok
Sign on Screen and Even in A number of Movies with 666 in the title such as 666 the devil's Child Route 666 and Even
1914 Officer 666
Super Humans and Evolution There is a widespread Belief Amongst Conspiracy Theorists that suggests the illuminati are Looking to Force Humanity to evolve Into A
Race of Superhumans and in Turn That
Superhero Movies Are Representative of How They want things to be movies like iron man Thor Captain America
Civil war Batman Vs Superman Dawn of Justice Deadpool and the Amazing Spider-man all
Showcased The Kind of super beings the illuminati want in The real World fact the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Superhero Films will Likely Converge Into A storyline That Ironically Involves A group of superheroes Called the Illuminati
Coincidence We Think not
Witchcraft in The Dark Arts There's A strong Belief Amongst Conspiracy Theorists that the illuminati are
Heavily Involved With Witchcraft and The Dark Arts Those are Common Themes in Hollywood movies Which Should Come as no surprise as
Hollywood's very Name Comes From the wood of the Holly Tree which is what magic wands are Classically Made out of movies like Those in
The Harry Potter and Lord of The rings Franchises Doctor Strange
Maleficent Hocus-Pocus And in Particular the Disney Classic Fantasia [A] movie that is absolutely rife With Illuminati Imagery in The eyes of
Conspiracists Are Said To represent the Dark Power that is possessed by the illuminati
Thanks for Watching our Video About 10 Hidden Illuminati secrets in your Favorite Hollywood Movies did you
Enjoy This Video [do] you know of Any other Dark secret signals in Blockbuster
Movies Have your Say in the Comments Section Below and Be Sure to subscribe to our Channel for more great Videos like this one